We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Sustainability is sustainability. Well, I think for a lot of people, sustainability is sustainability is an abstract thing.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学为所有生命提升生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马斯。可持续发展就是可持续发展。嗯，我认为对许多人来说，可持续发展是一个抽象的概念。
And as such, it's hard to sort of engage on the emotional level. It's really needed to push things forward. We want to inspire people rather than creating guilt trips or making them look at numbers. Sustainability is something that can be powerful and experiential and impact your life. My name is Anton Willis, I'm a designer and part of the studio called Civil Twilight. Civil Twilight's flagship project is lunar resident street lights. These are street lights that sense and respond to ambient moonlight.
正因如此，人们很难在情感层面上与之产生共鸣，而这正是推动事情向前发展所真正需要的。我们希望激发人们的灵感，而不是制造内疚感或让他们去看数字。可持续发展应该是一件强大且具有沉浸体验、能够影响你生活的事情。我叫安东·威利斯，是一名设计师，也是Civil Twilight工作室的成员。Civil Twilight的旗舰项目是月相感应路灯。这些路灯能够感应并响应周围的月光。
So they dim and brighten in response to the lunar cycle. When the moon is full, they dim down to save energy. It's both the way of saving energy and creating a new urban connection to the cycle of the moon. The project won the 2007 Metropolis next-generation design competition partly because it took this huge design challenge of trying to curb energy used and added a bit of the poetic design that saves energy but also inspires and reconnects urban dwellers with one of the fundamental cycles of nature. In most cities today the level of light pollution is so high that we're really not aware of
因此，它们会随着月相周期变暗和变亮。当月圆时，它们会变暗以节省能源。这既是一种节约能源的方法，也是一种建立城市与月球周期之间新联系的方式。该项目之所以赢得2007年大都会下一代设计竞赛，部分原因在于它接受了遏制能源消耗这一巨大的设计挑战，并融入了一点诗意的设计，既节约能源，又激励并重新连接了城市居民与自然的基本周期之一。在当今的大多数城市，光污染水平如此之高，以至于我们实际上根本意识不到
the stars or moonlight at all. No one knows what phase of the moon it is on any given day. So we're looking for a way to really reconnect people to those kinds of cycles. Each individual light has a very sensitive photo sensor that picks up moonlight, cloud cover, atmospheric conditions. So on the scale of a city, you could actually
星星或月光的存在。没有人知道今天是什么月相。因此，我们正在寻找一种方法，让人们重新与这些自然周期建立联系。每个独立的灯具都有一个非常敏感的光电传感器，可以捕捉月光、云层和大气条件。所以在城市的规模上，你实际上可以
have really interesting phenomenon. If a cloud passed over the moon, you could sort of see a shimmering across the city, reflecting the kind of cloud shadow. We see it as a pretty amazing way to make cities as a whole more more responsive and sort of more dynamic and more alive. It turns out that in the early years of street lighting both gas and electric gas and electricity was really expensive so they only turned them on when
看到非常有趣的现象。如果一朵云飘过月亮，你就可以看到整个城市泛起微光，反射出云影的形态。我们认为这是一个非常棒的方法，能让城市整体更具反应性、更有动态感、更有生命力。事实证明，在早期路灯使用的年代，无论是燃气还是电力，由于燃气和电力成本都很高，所以只有在
they needed to and they typically would not turn them on on full moon late nights when it was clear out. People just had the understanding that that was enough, like, to see by in cities and it was a waste of energy to light on top of that. And that really changed with the national grid electrification in the 1930s. When they actually needed a way to burn off excess energy at night when known was using electricity in their homes and the street light grid actually began as a way to do that as much as the way to eliminate cities. And since then almost every city has to be illuminated very brightly 24 hours a day.
需要时才会开启，而且通常在天气晴朗的满月之夜不会开灯。人们当时有一种共识，认为在城市里有这些光就足够看清路了，除此之外还要照明简直是浪费能源。这种情况随着20世纪30年代国家电网的电气化而发生了真正的改变。当时他们确实需要一种在夜间消耗过剩电力的方法，因为那时人们在家里不用电，而路灯电网的兴起，既是为了消耗多余电力，也是为了照亮城市。从那以后，几乎每个城市都必须在24小时内保持极其明亮的照明。
The standards for lighting that are in place come out of that period. So this is an effort to make a beautiful energy efficient version of a thing designed and used historically to burn energy on purpose. I think we've gotten used to talking about sustainability in terms of a lot of metrics and numbers and less about people's direct experience of it. So we're looking at ways to really bring it to a tangible personal experiential level. We see ourselves as part of a stronger direction that the whole sustainability movement will go, we believe, in the coming years. So where's my friendly neighborhood moon responsive street light? Well so far it only exists as a
现行的照明标准就是从那个时期开始的。因此，这是一项努力，旨在创造一个美丽且节能的版本，而这种设计和历史用途本来就是为了故意消耗能源。我认为我们已经习惯了用大量的指标和数字来谈论可持续发展，而较少关注人们对它的直接体验。因此，我们正在寻找真正将它带到切实、个人和体验层面的方法。我们认为自己是整个可持续发展运动未来几年将走向的更强有力方向的一部分，我们对此坚信不疑。那么，我那亲切的邻里月相感应路灯在哪里呢？好吧，到目前为止，它还只是一个
prototype so far. MIT labs are also prototyping a similar in spirit indoor adaptive lighting system as a massive energy saving technology but also as a way to make our working environments more comfortable, productive and pleasing through using more natural and responsive light. I think a lot of the current design discussion is about how to make design more relevant, how to make it part of these processes that really shape the world, the economics, the government, all of the sort of processes that we don't think of being designed or having a relationship to design. Climate change is a design problem. You know, the national debt is a design problem.
原型。麻省理工学院实验室也在制作一个精神相似的室内自适应照明系统原型，这不仅是一项巨大的节能技术，也是一种通过使用更自然、更有反应性的光线来让我们的工作环境更舒适、更高产、更愉悦的方法。我认为当前许多关于设计的讨论都集中在如何让设计更具相关性，如何让它成为塑造世界、经济、政府以及所有那些我们通常不认为与设计有关或有设计联系的过程的一部分。气候变化是一个设计问题。你知道，国债也是一个设计问题。
All of these things are design problems in different ways. If you expand the scope of how you think about it a little bit, our challenge as designers is really to expand that scope and to become part of bigger discussions. Sustainability. Sustainability. Sustainability. Sustainability. It's a project of K-A-L-W-D American Institute of Architects San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design.
所有这些在不同程度上都是设计问题。如果你稍微扩展一下思考这些问题的视野，我们作为设计师的挑战确实是扩展这种视野，并参与到更宏大的讨论中去。可持续发展。可持续发展。可持续发展。可持续发展。这是K-A-L-W、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。
Find out more at 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。